Hace 100 años, en 1917, la revolución rusa
se llevó por delante al imperio zarista.
Tras más de 3 siglos rigiendo por la fuerza
los destinos de Rusia, la dinastía de los
Romanov fue reemplazada - de forma sangrienta,
por cierto - por el régimen de la Rusia Soviética,
el embrión de lo que poco después se convirtió...
en la Unión Soviética..
Claro que... eso no significó, precisamente,
más libertad para el pueblo ruso.
Pero... insisto, en este vídeo no vamos a
hablar de historia, sino de presente, de lo
que algunos ven ya como el resurgir de una
nueva Rusia zarista.
Ahora bien, ¿realmente podemos hablar del
resurgir de una especie de Rusia zarista?
¿Os parece exagerado decir tal cosa? Veámoslo.
Por cierto, un apunte, relacionado con todo
esto: vamos a ver, también en este vídeo,
cuál es la forma más rápida para hacerse
rico, muy rico, multimillonario.
Y No, tranquilos ni me he vuelto loco ni vamos
ha hacer ningún anuncio raro. Luego veréis
por qué digo todo esto.
(UN NUEVO ZAR)
Hace 18 años, el 31 de diciembre de 1999,
un desconocido Vladimir Putin se convirtió
en el Presidente de Rusia. En 2018, casi con
total seguridad, Putin ganará las elecciones
y será elegido presidente por otro periodo
de 6 años.
Así que cuando termine su siguiente mandado
en 2024, decida continuar al frente o no,
lo cierto es que Putin habrá dirigido los
destinos de Rusia durante ¡25 años!
(Este es un periodo de tiempo mayor que el
de muchos reinados de los zares en la historia
de este gigantesco país.
Pero... no solo eso. Si algo podemos decir
ya hoy, es lo mucho que ha cambiado Rusia
desde que Putin llegó al poder, y sobre todo
el particular esquema, el sistema de Poder
que ha establecido.)
Un sistema amigos que recuerda mucho al de
la vieja Rusia de los Zares, pero eso sí,
aliñado con un poquito de la receta soviética.
Fijaos, por un lado, en el nuevo régimen
de Vladimir Putin se han restaurado dos de
los pilares fundamentales de la antigua URSS:
la propaganda y la represión.
(“El Kremlin responde con represión a las
mayores protestas en años en Rusia. El pasado
13 de junio de 2017, decenas miles de personas
marcharon en manifestaciones contra la corrupción
en toda Rusia [...] 1500 personas fueron arrestadas,
entre ellas el líder de la oposición, Alexei
Navalny” La Nación.)
Así es, con Putin al frente de Rusia, podemos
de decir que los servicios secretos y la polícia
política, lo que venía a ser la antigua
KGB y que hoy son conocidos como Servicio
Federal de Seguridad, han resucitado.
Junto a ello, una de las primeras cosas que
hizo Putin tras llegar al poder fue tomar
la televisión, asegurarse el control de los
medios de comunicación y poner en marcha
una potente campaña de exaltación patriótica
cuyo objetivo era algo así como decir:
Ey, Putín está aquí, la Rusia milenaria
vuelve a ser grande.
Pero, vale, si consideramos que el uso de
la propaganda y la represión es una herencia,
fundamentalmente, soviética ¿Por qué hablamos
de un nuevo Zar?
(Pues en parte por haber recobrado la estrecha
alianza Estado e Iglesia Ortodoxa....pero
sobre todo porque Putin ha consolidado un
estado controlado por una gran oligarquía
que recuerda mucho al modelo feudal o al de
monarquía - aristocracia de los tiempos del
Zar.)
Veréis...Putin ha sabido rodearse de un grupo
de amigos a los que les ha dado el control
de las grandes empresas del país y les ha
hecho de oro.
¿Recordáis cuando antes os comentaba que
en este vídeo ibamos a ver la forma más
rápida para hacerse multimillonario?
Pues esta es, precisamente, la fórmula: hacerse
amigo de Vladimir Putin. ¿No me creeis?
Pues atentos:
(Tenemos el caso de Sergei Roldugin, un amigo
de la infancia de Putin, que ha recibido cerca
de 2.000 millones de dólares en fondos estatales.
Hablamos también de personas muy cercanas
como Igor Sechin, antiguo jefe de gabinete
de Putin, Aleksei Miller, antiguo colaborador
y asesor de Putin o de Sergey Chemezov, antiguo
amigo de la KGB. Hoy todos ellos son multimillonarios
y presidentes de las mayores empresas públicas
del país: Gazprom, Rosneft y Rostec.)
No está mal ¿Verdad? Pero no penseis que
son casos aislados, para nada. Los ejemplos
se cuentan por montones: Timchenko, Rotenberg,
Kovalchuk, Shamalov…
Sí, decididamente podemos decir que a los
amigos de Putin no les va nada mal.
No es raro verles, por ejemplo, aparecer en
la lista forbes entre los más ricos del mundo.
Y no son solo ellos, como ya son multimillonarios
y se han hecho mayores, le están pasando
el testigo a sus hijos.
Hoy es normal ver como muchas de las grandes
empresas públicas de Rusia - que por cierto
se han multiplicado desde que Putin llegó
al Kremlin - están dirigidas por los hijos
de 25, 30 y 35 años, del entorno de Putin.
Fijaos en el caso de Nikolai Shamalov, amigo
de Putin, por supuesto... multimillonario,
y sus dos hijos. Uno, Yuri se convirtió muy
pronto en el Presidente de Gazfond, uno de
los fondos de pensiones más importantes de
Rusia.
El otro, Kirill a los 25 años ya era el VicePresidente
de Sibur, una gran compañía petroquímica
controlada por el gobierno ruso.
Por cierto, este chico, Kirill, poco después
se casó con la hija de Putin… y ¿sabéis
que? Hoy es considerado el joven más rico
de Rusia. Su fortuna supera los 1.000 millones
de dólares.
El propio primer ministro, Dmitri Medvédev,
ha sido acusado de haberse hecho multimillonario
y de tener palacios y viñedos por toda Rusia.
En la descripción os dejo el enlace al documental
que sacó toda esta historia a la luz.
Ahora bien, puede que te estés preguntando
¿Todo esto por qué? ¿Es acaso porque Putin
es un tipo muy generoso?
Pues... lo sea o no, esa no es la intención
en absoluto que persigue al hacer de oro a
su círculo cercano.
(Con esta estrategia Putin se ha garantizado
el control de prácticamente todos los resortes
de poder del estado. El y su camarilla lo
controlan todo. La factura, por supuesto,
corre a cargo de los ciudadanos rusos.)
Bien, oligarquía, represión, religión,
propaganda, control completo del estado y
de todos los resquicios económicos y políticos
de la sociedad rusa… estos son, amigos,
los ingredientes principales del régimen
político modelado por este particular nuevo
“Zar de Rusia”.
Por cierto, a veces en los comentarios nos
habéis preguntado porque tenemos una opinión
tan poco favorable del Presidente de Rusia.
Pues bien estos que hemos visto son los motivos.
Fijaos, más allá de posturas ideológicas,
en estas palabras de Owen Jones, un conocido
activista de izquierdas del que casi podríamos
decir que es el Iñigo Errejón británico:
(“Putin es un líder autoritario de derechas
que ataca las libertades civiles y discrimina
a las lesbianas, gays, bisexuales y transgénero,
se recrea en el nacionalismo más chovinista,
coquetea con los oligarcas más rapaces y
que es admirado por la extrema derecha europea
y estadounidense [...] Rusia está en manos
de un régimen oligárquico, expansionista
y que vulnera los derechos humanos. El pueblo
ruso y sus vecinos se merecen un Gobierno
mejor”. Owen Jones.)
Pero… llegados a este punto y visto el caso
de Rusia, puede que os estéis haciendo una
pregunta ¿Y fuera? ¿Cuánto poder tiene
realmente Vladimir Putin en el mundo?
Pues bien, como nos contó Alberto en un pasado
vídeo sobre China, podemos entender el poder
como la influencia, y podemos distinguir tres
ramas: militar, economía y política.
(EL RESURGIR DE UN TITÁN)
Vladimir Putin ha convertido a Rusia en uno
de los países que más esfuerzo realizan
en su ejército, muy por encima de Estados
Unidos o China.
Fijaos en este gráfico: Mientras que Estados
Unidos destina a su ejército aproximadamente
un 9% del presupuesto del gobierno, y China
en torno al 6, el caso de Rusia se dispara
por encima del 15%.
Y es que, amigos, si tras la caída de la
Unión Soviética, en los 90, la imagen habitual
de las fuerzas armadas rusas era de la barcos
que se oxidaban, aviones que no podían volar
y oficiales que vaciaban los arsenales para
vender armas en el mercado negro, hoy las
cosas son... muy diferentes.
Desde su llegada al poder y sobre todo a partir
de 2008, Putin ha fijado como una clara prioridad
modernizar el ejército.
Así que, en los últimos años se han gastado
decenas y decenas de miles de millones en
convertir al viejo ejército en una fuerza
de combate moderna, ágil y sobre todo con
una gran potencia de fuego.
Aviones, misiles, buques… todo está siendo
objeto de renovación.
Prestad atención, tan solo en 2015, según datos del
Ministerio de Defensa ruso, la armada recibió:
cuatro barcos, cuatro submarinos, 52 embarcaciones
auxiliares, 27 aeronaves y 45 unidades de
armamento de artillería.
Ahora bien, no penséis que está todo hecho,
para nada. Más allá de la propaganda del
propio gobierno ruso y su canales de comunicación:
(“Un ex-general de los Estados Unidos me
dijo que un único grupo de portaaviones de
los Estados Unidos podría destruir a toda
la marina de guerra rusa, ya que el equipo
que utilizan está anticuado y su tecnología
obsoleta”. Azeem Ibrahim.)
En cualquier caso, podemos decir que el ejército
ruso se ha convertido en el referente clave
de la política internacional de Moscú.
Y no solo por su capacidad para influir sobre
otros países y conflictos internacionales,
sino también por la renovada capacidad de
la industria armamentística rusa para vender
en el extranjero.
Sí, amigos, sí a todo esto le añadimos
su arsenal nuclear, queda claro que Rusia
todavía... cuenta.
(¿PIES DE BARRO?)
Ahora bien, si podemos considerar al ejército
ruso como una baza para Vladimir Putin, la
desastrosa economía rusa es con toda seguridad
su gran debilidad.
Mirad, amigos,Rusia es básicamente un productor
y un exportador de recursos naturales. Su
economía no tiene nada que ver con la china,
por ejemplo.
A lo largo de las últimas décadas no ha
conseguido ni diversificarse ni desarrollar
una economía productiva y compleja, para
nada.
Rusia cada vez es más dependiente de sus
recursos naturales, de tal forma que cuando
los precios de estos productos están altos…
todo va viento en popa… pero cuando caen.
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya vimos los problemas
a los que Rusia se enfrentó con la caída
de los precios del petróleo. Os dejo el enlace
a este vídeo en la descripción.
Pues bien, atentos a las palabras de Barack
Obama en su última rueda de prensa como presidente:
("Rusia es un país más pequeño. Es un país
más débil. Su economía no produce nada
que nadie quiera comprar, excepto el petróleo
y el gas y las armas. No innovan”. Obama.)
Y todo esto tiene una explicación en la que
el estado oligárquico creado por Vladimir
Putin tiene mucho que ver.
Mirad, desde el año 2005 el peso del Estado
de la economía ha pasado del 35% al 70%.
(Todo este proceso ha estado determinado por
la creación de empresas públicas dirigidas
por los amiguetes de Putin. Y, claro, en este
contexto sobra la corrupción y no hay ni
competencia ni incentivos para hacer las cosas
bien.
Por eso los pronósticos sobre la economía
rusa suelen ser bastante pobres.)
Por cierto, en 2016, más de 400.000 personas,
400.000, emigraron del país...especialmente
los jóvenes bien cualificados..
En fin, no parece amigos que el modelo económico
de la Rusia de Putin sea capaz de propiciar
el crecimiento y desarrollo del país.
Y además, pensádlo, en sí mismo esto supone
una debilidad muy importante:
(Una pobre economía reduce el interés de
Rusia para el resto de actores mundiales y
por tanto su influencia. Una pobre economía
conllevará tarde o temprano el declive paulatino
de las capacidades militares del país, que
es la última gran baza de influencia que
le queda a Moscú.)
Respecto a la tercera rama, el poder político,
podemos hablar de los últimos movimientos
con China, de la estrategia rusa en oriente
medio donde Moscú quiso dar el relevo al
mismísimo Washington.
Pero creo amigos que todo esto lo dejaremos
para otro vídeo, así que ya sabes, no olvides
suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Por cierto, ¿Qué opinión tienes de Vladimir
Putin?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Por supuesto si
el vídeo te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima